so one of the things we talked about at
my show all the time is our food sources
here in America you know all the
subsidies core and all that stuff I was
watching an interview that you did and
you were talking about just a
plant-based diet and how it can affect
our bodies and our minds and the economy
and all this stuff so I thought it was
an interesting place to jump off with
you on this is how important is food in
general to the environment just the
stuff that we take in how important is
that to the bigger environmental picture
there's a friend of mine he was a cattle
rancher feedlot operator and he says
that the fork is one of the most
dangerous weapons we've ever held in our
hand and I think there's some truth to
that again I don't want to dictate to
anybody what they eat my wife eats meat
and I don't really give her a hard time
about it she eats it rarely but she does
on occasion yeah it's a fair amount of
chicken and fish and what have you
things like that I'm a vegan myself
because I think it's good for me I
really feel very good when I eat a
plant-based diet and it's certainly good
for the ecosystem it just takes so much
more water and land an energy to grow a
pound of beef and it does a pound of
broccoli yeah so that's something we
have to consider even for the
meat-eaters to eat as I suppose my wife
does you know just a few times a year or
a few times a month if you're a big
meteor just cut down a bit see if you
can live with that and see how you like
it or there's other substitutes now you
know in the old days that was what we
had to do to survive it's a different
world now you can be up in Fairbanks at
juneau you can get veggie dogs and
broccoli in the middle of winter you
know it's just a different world that we
live in yeah and so I think a
plant-based diet is a very good way to
go and certainly when you're growing
yourself it's quite economical you can
make very cheap vegetables if you do it
that way if not if you buy and lots of
you know plan amendments that are
expensive and water tap water with
coming from a meter you know you can
wind up with eight dollar tomatoes if
you're not careful very sure how much is
it is that we're just hugely separated
from our food sources you know they do
all these studies or something like the
average chicken that you might get a
trader joes came from 2,000 miles away
or something crazy we're only a hundred
years ago you pretty much lived in a
village or pretty much close by where
you were getting
food from it comes such great distances
now people just want their damn grapes
in the middle of winter they come from
Chile of course you know they want
different things you can do that but it
comes at great cost I try to eat
seasonally as best I can you know
nobody's perfect but I go to the farmers
market there in Studio City yep to
supplement what I can't grow myself but
I've been growing food since I've had my
very first home in 1979 before that of
his apartment renter you know and I
couldn't I couldn't grow food back then
they didn't have community gardens away
they do now now if you don't have fewer
an apartment you don't have a piece of
dirt your front or backyard you can get
part of a community garden if they don't
have one you can start one yeah there's
a lot of that available but I've shown
my kids who are now 36 and 37 who both
are Master Gardeners I've shown them
where food comes from it doesn't come
from the ralphs tree the safeway push it
comes from soil and water and sunshine
and that's how you make food what do you
think about the other part of it not
just the stuff that you're putting in
your system to stay alive but sort of
the therapeutic part of it because I
have an apartment but I have a little
little front area where I grow some n
tomatoes and some mint and you know a
bunch of herbs and things like that and
I find just clipping the stuff I
actually find it calms me down it gets
me away from my phone and all the
electronics and I feel like that's an
important piece of it too just for your
mental state as a human you know you're
connecting their into the big one now I
know I myself have one of these smart
device i'm looking at hey man there's a
great website for yosemite we got a look
at this website for yellowstone it put
the thing away put in your pocket turn
off get to yosemite yes yellowstone if
not if you're not inclined to do that
you have time just get out to your
garden and you don't have a garden get
part of a community garden is you're
suggesting if you get your hands in the
dirt it's the ultimate therapy you feel
connected again to what our real riches
are I think I get my paycheck from Sony
Pictures or from Warner Brothers a
universal studios that's not where I get
my real paycheck from that's right by a
bunch of stuff stuff like home shopping
network stuff and some stuff perhaps a
little more important than that but
mostly mostly I'm buying stuff with the
money that I make at my suppose a job my
real income I think is from the soil and
the water and the sunshine to grow food
and be part of that system that's what
we really need
water clean air and food and that's our
real well that's a real paycheck yeah
now you're not telling Sony that it
would be okay to pay you in composting
right it was a nice sentiment III think
I may have misspoke you may have
misspoken